welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and Daredevil just slid into the
MCU almost as fast as he slid into our
hearts wow I just got out of the
intelligencia mailing list unsubscribe
And subscribe Charlie Cox says Matt
Murdoch changed our lives with his Cameo
and Spider-Man no way home as an expert
attorney who got Peter Parker off the
hook and now as the attorney for a
superhero costumer who knows his
identity Daredevil just got himself off
ah phrasing this team up between
Daredevil and She-Hulk not only gave us
a thrilling half hour of streaming
content their budding relationship just
changed the entire legal landscape of
the MCU as phase four shifts into phase
five so as we look ahead to Jen
hopefully showing up in Daredevil born
again will this end in the launch of the
firm up Nelson and Murdoch and Walters
or these two horndogs venting that JD
energy on opposite sides of a civil war
dispute it was love at first sight for
Jenn and Matt or Cipher gin but
heartbeat eavesdropper Matt and he could
even tell by the way Jen first responded
to her new opposing Council who's this
[ __ ] I guess you gotta work at these
things but Jen goes on oh if the
defendant has nothing to hide then why
not hear from his clients I would say
that's a gross invasion of people's
privacy based on a very shaky what if oh
man you may not be speaking gent love
language but you're totally speaking of
mine a very shaky what if indeed he
could have said a more lawyerly shaky
hypothetical but no he said what if as
this rivalry turned partnership and even
Charlie Cox Matt and Murdoch's presence
here strikes many viewers as a dream
scenario what if episode especially
considering this Daredevil just
completed this crossover from the
Netflix side of the universe seemingly
fully intact he introduces himself with
the same theme music from John Paisano
so are you like a superhero like the
gold devil
I'm a daredevil
and his response there means he expected
Jen to know who Daredevil is meaning the
guy's a reputation in New York City the
devil of Hell's Kitchen already based on
at least a few years worth of vigilante
work the guys figured out his brand his
iconography his Gear with his padded
body armor and his horns and his baton
connected by a chain he is a true Man
Without Fear when it comes to combat
well versed in the same kind of flips
and rolls and parkour that he would do
in the Netflix series and he's street
smart enough to know the difference
between goons and henchmen and yeah
Daredevil and as an attorney he's in the
middle of a busy career well I run my uh
practice in the Hell's Kitchen and we
mostly do pro bono work the uh us part
but I do on occasion take a job with a
bigger client when the bills start
piling up
the event part yes you heard that right
he said we mostly do pro bono work we
say his name Matt foggy Nelson is MCU
Cannon seal will likely end with Jen
Walters leaving GLK and H to start her
own firm or maybe to become in-house
counsel to MC organizations like The
Avengers or the sorcerers or the
Thunderbolts or hey why not the TBA they
need a lawyer everybody does but her
reunion with Matt Murdoch in Daredevil
born again now seems inevitable the
series is gonna run 18 episodes when it
releases in 2024 and it's said to begin
production early next years so there's
still time to sure or throw her a couple
episodes while Charlie Cox has
downplayed how much She-Hulk will set up
born again he did leave the door open in
d23 so because you know we way to go
that one
to come and maybe do it at the Lark in
our show Cox so far has been a bit
cryptic about the plot of the Daredevil
Born Again series confirming it would
not be a fourth season of the Netflix
Daredevil series but rather be a kind of
tonal reset for the character I don't
think that's meant to erase his entire
history from the Netflix Seasons but I
also don't expect him to often reference
that time he I don't know teamed up with
other Defenders to fight the hand based
on Matt's chemistry with Jen it seems
possible they could partner up
professionally as Nelson and Murdoch and
Walters or it'd probably be like Walters
and Nelson and Murdoch yeah in that case
foggy would be the meat of that sandwich
lucky man then again I'm not so sure
because this episode outlined a clearer
philosophical division between these two
people that I think would make their
romantic chemistry more complicated and
thus more fun to watch in future
team-ups have you ever stopped yourself
from getting a little treat because you
just broke the bank on a tank of gas or
a big load of groceries we've all done
that mental math in our heads and
deprived ourselves of that pumpkin spice
latte we rightfully deserve but our
friends at upside are here to get you
some cash back on those expensive
purchases so you can be as pumpkin spice
does your heart desires upside is a free
app that lets you earn cash back on
everyday purchases like gas groceries or
dinner it's easy to use and it works for
me upside is essential for buying gas
when my Tank's on empty I open the
upside app search for a nearby gas
station offering a good deal claim it
and then head there to buy the gas I can
check in or snap a pic of the receipt
and then I'm good to go no special cards
to carry or numbers to remember just
upside zap already on my phone anytime I
want I can cash out on my bank account
PayPal or an e-gift card for Amazon or
other brands upside users are earning
more than a million dollars every week
and it has a 4.8 star rating on the app
store to get started download the free
upside app and use the code new
rockstars to get five dollars or more
cash back on your first purchase of 10
or more Jen was arguably just doing her
best to represent her client Eugene
patillio but her debate with Matt got
personal there is no inherent right to
privacy when employing Mr Jacobson's
tailoring Services well we're not just
talking about a product here or in
nature of Mr Jacobson's line of work
making suits exclusively for superheroes
necessitates anonymity
may I remind you that the sokovia courts
have been repealed I started to go into
this in another video but we
recovery Accords is a major legal press
phase of the MCU Captain America Civil
War established that being an
unregistered Anonymous superhero is a
violation of international law but since
the Segovia Accord seemed more aimed at
the Avengers and the aftermath of their
collateral damage in Age of Ultron it
makes sense that it would be overruled
in the aftermath of their Redemptive
victory in Avengers end game kind of
like a pardoned all the Avengers for you
know bringing half of everyone back to
life still the philosophical debate over
superhero oversight registration ain't
going anywhere in fact it's probably
going to become more and more of a
problem in the MCU now that this
universe is flooding with unlicensed
mutants and super soldiers
extraterrestrials Wizards crazy
Engineers the debate over whether
superheroes have a right to anonymity
was addressed in the First Act of Civil
War but they quickly moved on from it as
the conflict of that movie became more
centered around the personal Feud among
Tony Bucky and Kat I would argue made
for a better movie but the core debate
that made the Civil War comic event so
interesting was really left behind and
never fully answered which is why it's
really exciting to see this episode of
She-Hulk green it back to the Forefront
superheroes operate in the public eye as
public figures it is assumed that there
will be some loss of privacy the
distinction here is we're not talking
about celebrities talking about
superheroes who have enemies who will
try to harm them and the people close to
them the ones who didn't ask to be a
part of this life
now Ms Walters chose to have her
identity be public but it is enough to
her to choose for everyone else damn a
really low blow there for Matt Miss
Walters chose to have her identity be
public I mean it wasn't jyn's choice to
get Bruce's blood but unlike Bruce she
can choose whether or not to Hulk out
and he uses this ad hominem attack by
implying Jen is a privileged celebrity
yes he is being a bit of a hypocrite as
he is defending his own choice of
anonymity as a vigilante outside the law
but either way both of these lawyers
remain on totally opposite sides of a
spectrum on this issue so with the
sokovia Accords out of the way this
debate over superhero privacy and
registration can totally return to the
MCU removed from the exceptionalism of
the Avengers and instead get explored on
a case-by-case basis from the point of
views of the newcomers to this franchise
and while they can be fought in various
ways with powers and weaponry in the
courtroom representing those factions
can be on the pro-registration side She
Hulk and on the anti-registration side
Daredevil the MCU is now perfectly set
up for a true Civil War conflict not
just in one movie but an ongoing
miniseries that involves since nulls and
mutants and all the other new Heroes who
prepare anonymity and need an advocate
to represent their interests so opposing
them leading team She-Hulk we get
Jennifer Walters and joining her I think
you
were Captain Marvel Monica Rambo Kamala
Khan Doctor Strange Wong Thor the
asgardians the Illuminati if they're
still alive somewhere in the Multiverse
or in this reality and depending on how
much they'd like to play ball with
oversight double condens and Shang chi I
really think that lists are the proud
public celebrity Heroes meanwhile on
team Daredevil I think we'd have the
anonymous Peter Parker I mean who even
is that guy the Thunderbolts Hawkeye
Moon Knight werewolf by night man thing
Wanda if she's still alive somewhere
Wolverine and Deadpool and given these
characters reasons to distrust the
government Captain America Sam Wilson
Scott Lang Cassie Lang hope Van Dyne and
Hank Pym also probably most of the
mutants so things are pretty balanced on
either side of that battle line and
Marvel Studios could simply boil us down
to Avengers vs X-Men or Fantastic Four
versus a freaks I want to know which
team would you be on follow me on Tick
Tock Instagram and Twitter at eavos
follow new rockstars And subscribe to
new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
thank you
[Music]